สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนโค่น
มามา
เขียนวันนั้นนะคะได้ค่ะควันเดิม
ที่แล้วนะคะ
ครูหญิงคะวันนั้นนี่วันนี้แล้วนะคะพระเอก
แอ๊บในไงกูลบก่อนไม่ลบอ่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
29 ค่ะวันที่ 29 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
เมื่อปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565  a ขอศ.เท่าไหร่คะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
04:54 นาที
04:54 นาทีนะคะๆค่ะก็ก็วันนี้คลิปนี้ก็
ต่อกับคลิปที่แล้ว
ใส่ค่ะคลิปที่แล้วเนี่ยเราพูดถึง
ถึงเดือนใช่ไหมคะเดือนในเดือนมกราคมราคา
เดือนมกราคม
ถึงเดือนอะไรคะผู้หญิงเดือนมิถุนายนค่ะ
กับอ่ะเอ่ออัญมณีใต้อัญมณีกับเดือนเกิด
เดี๋ยววันนี้กับเดือนเกิดนะคะเรารีวิวนิด
นึงเนาะนี่นายค่ะดีเดือนมกราคม
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรคะใส่โกเมนค่ะสีอะไรคะสีแดง
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ใส่อัญมณีอะไรคะ
ไก่อเมทิสค่ะสีอะไรคะสีม่วง
เดือนมีนาคมใส่อัญมณีอะไรคะใส่อะความารีน
ค่ะสีอะไรคะสีฟ้าน้ำทะเลสีฟ้าน้ำทะเล
เดือนเมษายนใส่อัญมณีอะไรคะไก่เพชรค่ะสี
อะไรคะสีขาวสีใสไม่
F4 รีสีก็เลยแพงจริงๆเพชรมีสีสีน้ำเงิน
มีสีมีสีมีสีนะครูหญิงหรอ
เพชรก็มีสิทธิ์สีน้ำเงิน
ใครขัน
สีชมพู
อ๋อแต่ว่าสีขาวแพง 4 เนี้ย
สีขาวสีชมพูแพงฮัลโหลผิงไม่เข้าใจเลยนะคะ
ไม่เป็นมีชมพูแพงมากหรอแปลว่ามีน้อยสิ
แล้วก็สีน้ำเงินก็แพงว่าหมอก็เลยไม่มีคน
เห็นใช่ไหมคะ
Blue  Diamond หน้าวีออกเหลืองและมีเยอะ
ๆนะคะอ้าอ้า
ต่อไปค่ะเดือนที่ห้าเดือนที่ 5 ใส่อะไรคะ
อ่ะกไก่มรกรหรือหรือหยกหยกสีอะไรคะสี
เขียวค่ะสีเขียวแล้วเราก็จบเดือนที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนค่ะใส่อะไรคะไข่
มุกสีอะไรคะสีขาวค่ะสีดำด้วยใช่ไหมคุยบอก
มีสีขาวสีดำสีชมพูและมากๆจะสีขาวปากสีขาว
ออกอ้าววันนี้เราก็มาต่อเดือนที่ 6 แล้ว
ใช่ไหมคะขาดที่ 7 นะคะเดือนที่ 7 เดือน
ที่ 7 เดือนอะไรคะครูหญิงเดือน
กรกฎาคมเดือนที่ 7 นะคะเดือนกรกฎาคมค่ะ
แล้ว
กรกฎาคมใครถามหญิงถามสิอุ้ยไม่รู้จักครู
เอ๋โทรหาเดือนกรกฎาคมเนี่ยคนที่เกิดเดือน
กรกฎาคม
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรดีใส่ทับทิมค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ 2  2 อันเนี้ยของทีมเม็ดสองเม็ด
สองเม็ดอะไร 2 เม็ดใส่ค่ะ 2 เม็ดนี้เนี่ย
คือทับทิมเหรอคะถ้ามีทับทิมสีแดงนะคะ
เรียกว่าทับทิมสยามโอโอ๊โอฟังชื่อก็ดูแพง
เนาะไข่ไทยทับทิมทำอะไรอ่ะไม่มีแล้วขอแค่
แห้งมาก
หนูค่ะแล้วอ้าอันนี้ทับทิม
ทับทิมสีชมพูก็ทับถิ่นก็จะมีทีมแมนมาก
ทับทิมกาญจนบุรีทับทิมอ่า
เกาะมาดากัสการ์
จำแม่นสีชมพูนะคะจะพัดสีแดงอันนี้สีแดงอะ
นี้ทับทิมสยามค่ะผู้หญิงเริ่มสงสัยไหม
ทับทิม
แล้วก็
เบาะโก้
ทำไมสีแดงเหมือนกันคะรู้สมัยเรียกไม่
เหมือนกันอ่ะกูเอามาลงไว้ใกล้ๆกัน
ถ้าครูหญิงดูไม่เข้าใจเม็ดไหนทับทิมเม็ด
ไหนโกเมนคู่เอกเข้าใจ
ทำไมครูเอกเข้าใจดูยังดูยังไงที่บอกนะไม่
เขาบีกินเนอร์หนึ่ง
ยิ่งอธิบายไม่ถูกแต่ทับทิมน่ะทับทิมน่ะ
ข้างในเหมือนมีอะไรแล้วก็จะแบบอามานี่วัน
นี้เวลาเราด้วยว่ากูเองรู้สึกมานี่
แปลว่ารัฐเป็น
เป็นโกเมนน่ะดูแล้วก็เฉยๆออกแล้วครูเอ๋
เนี่ยบอกกูยังไม่ค่อยชอบกู mayne เขตชอบ
ทับทิมสยามไหมคะจริงๆครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่ชอบสี
แดงเอาอ๋อ
ไม่ชอบสีแดงแต่กูเอกก็มีและมีสีแดงนางอาจ
ทับทิมสยามเนี่ยคิดว่าครูเหมไม่ชอบเพราะ
ว่าแพงมากๆผู้หญิงคิดเรียกครูเอกก็จะสวย
ไม่ชอบก็
น้ำครับครูหญิงอยากจะถามอะไรต่อคะไม่เห็น
มีไหมคะทับทิม
มีค่ะอ้าวคุยไม่ชอบแต่มี hue อันนี้
ทับทิมอะไรคะพี่ฟิล์มธรรมดาภัทรินทร์เฉย
งูกูแอบแพงไหมคะเรยค่ะอ๋อ press ใส่
ไม่ใส่
หรือไม่ใส่ก็ไม่สวยชุดทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูเอ๋
สีแดงไม่สวยน้องเออเอ๋ก็เคมีด้วยนะสร้อย
เอกคับฟิตฝั่งนั้น
โหครูเอ๋ใส่สร้อยเราก็ใส่สร้อยข้อมือ
ทับทิมมาสอนนักเรียนไม่ใส่ครูเอ๋ผิวขาวเก
ชอบ
อันเนี้ยมันเป็นสีทองมันเป็นอันนี้นะแต่
ว่าทองนะคะถ้าไม่ใช่ทองบางทีใส่แล้วว่า
เป็นทองครูเอ๋แต่ไม่ชอบทองขลุ่ยชอบไหมคะ
ไม่ชอบค่ะสองคนไม่ชอบทองผู้หญิงคิดว่าทอง
บวกทับทิมไม่ค่อยสวยค่ะ
แต่คู่เอกก็เปลี่ยนไม่ได้เพราะอันนี้อะ
อันนี้ปลื้มคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่
อ่ะอันนี้เหละค่ะให้พี่สาวพี่ใส่น้องชาย
พี่สาวนะมีพี่มีแม่มีพี่
พี่สาวของแม่เนี่ยให้
ครูเอ๋ออกครูเอก็จะแบบให้คนอื่นก็ไม่ได้
ใช่ขายก็ไม่ได้ได้ไม่เอาไม่ได้ให้ครูหญิง
หญิงไม่เอา
ออกให้
คุณครูคิดๆกูหญิงใส่ทองแล้วก็มีเสื้อทีม
สีแดงแล้วก็เดินสินะ
ฉันเห็นผู้หญิงให้เอ๋ทำไม
คุณคนจีนไงพูดเอ๋เค้าคิดกูเอ๋ใส่สวยๆคุณ
ป้าน่ะให้เอ๋จ๊ะเอ๋ไม่ชอบแอบชอบแบบนี้ค่ะ
ชอบใส่ช่องเงิน
สแตนเลสอันนี้ไม่รู้เหมือนกันอ่าไม่รู้
อะไรนะคะชอบสีนี้ค่ะอะไรแรกสีเงินนะคะหาก
ไม่ชอบสีทองใช่ไหมชอบสีทองอันนี้อะไรอัน
นี้เป็นโกเมนออกไปที่ 7 ต้องใส่ทับทิมดี
ค่ะค่ะโอ้วแล้วเดือนต่อไปเดือนที่ 8
เดือนเขียวๆเดือนที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะผู้
หญิงเดือนสิงหา
คำคมเดือนที่ 8 นะคะเดือน
สิงหาคมค่ะครูเอ๋คะเดือนสิงหาคมคนที่เกิด
เดือนสิงหาคม
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรดีอันนี้เขาบอกว่าใส่
เพอริดอทออนี่ชื่อเพอริดอทเหรอคะใช่
เคอรี่ .
คู๋นะคิดว่าน่าจะใส่อันนี้อันไหนคะเนี่ย
ค่ะเอาอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋ภาษาไทย
ใช่ไหมภาษาไทยค่ะภาษาไทยเนี่ยเขียวส่อง
ภาษาอังกฤษอ่ะคะ Green ซัฟไฟร์ออกผู้หญิง
ไม่เคยได้ยินภาษาไทยผู้หญิงเนี่ยกูเองพูด
เขียวส่องอ่ะกูเอ๋พูด Green  Soft อะไรนะ
ซัลไฟด์อามาอย่ารู้จักรู้จักวันนี้สวยนะ
ครูเอ๋นักเรียนครูเอกก็ดูหลายๆเว็บตอนนี้
เว็บก็บอกว่าใส่เพอริดอทคู่เอกก็เวลากู
เองเด็กๆไม่มีผลิต . มีป่ะจะเดี๋ยวส่อง
เขียวส่งอาจจะแพงหรือเปล่าคะหาไม่ได้ไม่
แพงแต่พูดแค่มีอันนี้ฟรีเหมือนกันแบบไม่
ได้ทำแหวนโอเคคุยเอาค่ะถึงบ้านคุยให้ไม่
เอาพูดเล่นไม่มีที่ออฟฟิศใช่มาโหไหนขอดู
ได้
รู้จักค่ะ
มันมองไม่เห็นมันมันเล็กก็
เหมือนครูเอ๋เหมือนกันเลย
ถึง 7 อะไรขนาดนั้นให้ผู้หญิงได้นะไม่เอา
ผิงไม่รู้ทำอะไรผู้หญิงอ่าใส่ต่างหูไม่
ใส่สร้อยคอมาให้ใส่แหวนไม่ใส่สร้อยข้อมือ
ให้ครูหญิงเอาไปทำแหวนให้ไม่เอาซะ
แหวน 2 แหวนผู้หญิงชอบแหวนไม่มีอะไรเห
รอริกา
เอาเดือนสิงหาคมให้ใส่สีเขียวนะคะจะเป็น
เขียวแบบนี้เขียวแบบเคอรี่ . ตอนหัว xxx
เด็กอ่ะคู๋ได้ยินว่าใส่เขียวส่องทอก็
เขียวแต่เขียวไม่เหมือนกันเน๊อะเขียวส่อง
มาดูเป็นเขียวเข้มๆสีดำๆตะเขียวอันนี้ก็
เขี๊ยวเขียวๆเลยเพลงอันนี้เขียวแบบเขียว
เขียวไหม
ชอบเขียวสองอันนี้เขียวสะอาด
เดือนต่อไป
เดือนที่ 9 ค่ะอยากรู้เหมือนที่ 9 เดือน
อะไรคะครูหญิงเดือนที่ 9 เดือนกันยายน
เดือน
กันยายนใช่ไหมคะพี่พูดถูกใช่ไหมใช่สี
เดือนที่ 9 เดือนกันยายนเต็มก็ได้ค่ะค่ะ
ครูเองอะไรคะก่อนก็ได้ค่ะเดือนกันยายนค่ะ
ชอบแย่งกันพูดนักเรียนขอโทษด้วยนะคะไม่
เอ๋ยคะคนที่เกิดเดือนกันยายน
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรดี
ชื่ออะไรคะ
ภาษาไทย
เมื่อกี้เป็น
เขียวสองอันนี้ฟ้า 2 ใครลินขอใครรินออก
ภัยรนด์เนอยู่ที่กัมพูชามากๆคะแต่
บางก่อนกัมพูชาไข่ไม่มีนะฮือครูเอ๋มีไหม
คะไพลินมีค่ะ Way บอกไทยไม่มีแล้วทำไมครู
เอ๋มีเอกก็ซื้อไงคะอ๋อ
ก็ต้องซื้อจากกัมพูชามามาแล้วก็ทำไม่มี
เป็นอะไรคะพี่ขอดีจี้ผู้หญิงนั้นอยู่ใช่
ไหมอยากดูค่ะนี่เป็นสีน้ำเงินใช่ไหมคะครู
เอ๋สีน้ำงานกูน้ำเงินมากเลยอ่ะด้วยนะ
สวยค่ะแต่ว่าแมกซ์
รูเอคะครูเอ๋จำได้ไหมว่าครูเอ๋ซื้อมาราคา
เท่าไหร่
แพงอยู่ 8 คัน 500 คู่เอกเล็กๆขนาดนี้นะ
คะอ่ะที่ดินแพง
คุย
จ่ายค่ะ 8,000 แปดพัน 500 บาทเล็กๆ
ไม่มากกว่านี้นะน่าจะไม่มากกว่าเนี่ยไม่
น้อยกว่า 8 ลูกน้ำ 500 บาทผู้หญิงซื้อ 30
ปีที่แล้ว
ตอนนี้เลยตอนนี้เนี่ย
2022 คู๋ซื้อ
1992 นะคะ
30 ปีที่แล้วตอนนี้ก็บวกบวกบวก
ไปค่ะไม่รู้คิดว่าน่าจะแพงกว่าเมื่อก่อน
ไม่รู้ไม่รู้
ไพลินไพลินไพลินเมื่อก่อนกูแอบชอบใครริญ
มากๆหากเปลี่ยนชอบหยกค่ะหนู
การทำงานได้เงินไม่ซื้อกระเป๋านักผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงมากๆซื้อกระเป๋าครูเอ๋ไม่ซื้อค่ะ
ลิปสิไม่ซื้อเพื่อไปซื้ออะไรนะพาไปชะโด
ไม่ซื้อ
ให้กะไปซื้อ
กูเองเงินหมดนะคะซื้ออัญมณี
หือปั่นต่อไปค่ะ
เตรียมต่อไปเดือนอะไรคะเดือนที่ 10 ใช่
ไหมคะครูเอ๋
เดือนทิส 15 อะไรคะผู้หญิงเดือน
ตุลาคมเดือนตุลาคมครูเอ๋คะคนที่เกิดเดือน
ตุลาคม
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรดีไปยังไม่มีใครใส่โอปอหมอ
ครูเอ๋โอปอล์มีหลายหลายสีเหรอคะใช่โอปอมี
หลายๆสีแล้วก็ใน 1 เม็ดก็มีหลายๆสี
สวยดีนะสวยๆอุ้ยงั้นถ้าครูหญิงมีโอปอล์ 1
เม็ดสีชมพูฟ้า
คนอื่นก็มากมีเหมือนครูหญิงหรอก็น่าจะมี
เหมือนได้หรอเอาน่ามันจะมันจะไม่ได้
เหมือน
100% ไงกูเอก
[เพลง]
แล้วครูเอ๋เอ๋มีโอปอล์ไหมคะจริงๆกูเอมี่ 1
นะอ้าอยู่ที่ไหนหายไปแล้วอ้าวไม่ใช่คุย
อิ๋งแล้วนักเรียน
หายไปค่ะหายนักเรียนป
ก็เข้าไปไหนเดี๋ยวๆครูเอ๋โอปอแพงไหมคะไม่
รู้มีคนให้ครูเอ๋ฟรี
ก็ไม่เป็นไรไม่รู้ว่าแพงหรือไม่แพงหาย
โอเคการจริงๆน่าจะแพงนะครูหญิงโอปอล์
อัญมณีออสเตรเลียคุย
สเตรเลียมีมากๆหรอคะภัยไม่มีอ๋อครูเอ๋ไป
ออสเตรเลีย
ทำงานเก็บเงินก่อน
เก็บเงินซื้อที่ถ่ายน่าจะเท่ากัน
คนเกิดเดือนตุลาคมใส่โอปอลล์ดีค่ะค่ะก็มี
หลายๆสีด้วย
ต่อไป
วันนี้ก็สวยนะคะเดือนที่ 21 ค่ะครูเอ๋
เดือนที่ 11 นะคะรึ
เดือนที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนค่ะช่วยฮะคนที่เกิดเดือน
พฤศจิกายน
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรดี
ใส่อ่า
บุษราคัมชื่อ
บทศราคัมสีเหลืองสีเหลืองมันอยู่ในกลุ่ม
ซัฟไฟร์เหมือนๆอันนี้แหวนไพลินไพลินเขียว
ส่อง
เขียวซองไพลินบุษราคัมเป็นซัฟฟาย
ต้องฝ่ายไม่เหมือนหยกไม่เหมือนฝากกดใบ
เหมือนไม่เหมือนทับทิมไม่เหมือน
ไม่เข้าใจนะคะเป็นไร
ดู a ฮะครูเอ๋มีบุษราคัมไหมกูเอไม่มี
บุษราคัมครูเอกช่อบุษราคัมว่าทำไมชอบอ่ะ
กูเห็นชอบสีเหลืองเหรอคะ
บุษราคัมไม่ใช่เหลืองนะกูหญิงหรอจะเป็นสี
ผู้หญิงทุกคนดูเป็นสีเหลืองใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะสีเหลืองสีเหลืองสีส้ม
ออ
ใช่สีพรุ่งนี้เหมือนสีส้มเลยนะตัวเองห้า
สีก่อนสีแต่นะจะมีไหมสีน้ำตาลอ่ะเนาะ
โง่ๆอ่า 4 ตัวนี้ก็ได้สีน้ำตาลถ้าคุยหญิง
เห็นนะคะเค้าจะมีสีแบบ
ของตาลโคนน้ำตาลเหลืองส้มใช่คือไม่ใช่
เหลือง
ไม่ใช่เรื่องเหลืองอ่ะอ่ะกูก็คือแล้วแต่
เรามองมองอย่างนี้หรอครับมุ่งตรงไหนอย่าง
เงี้ยๆนะคะก็จะมองแล้วแต่มองว่ายังไงก็จะ
เป็นเหลืองเหลืองส้มน้ำตาลนี้เอกก็เลยชอบ
มันเหมือน 1 สีแต่เหมือนๆมี 3 สี
หรือแต่คุยอุจจาระคำแพงอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ไม่มีครูเอกก็เลยซื้ออันนี้มาแพนซื้ออะไร
คะครูเอ๋จะเปิดได้ไหมน่าจะต้องเปิดได้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋กูเองเก่งค่ะเธอเก่งมากค่ะเก่งมาก
บิ๊ก
อันแบบนี้กูหญิงยังหาไม่เจอเลยเค้าก็นึก
ถึงไหน
เปิดๆแล้วเย้
อะไรคะครูเอ๋มีอะไร
เดี๋ยวคุยต้องสต๊อกสกรีนพรึบได้ค่ะ
อุ้ยครูอันนี้สีอะไรคะสีคล้ายๆบุษราคัม
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะส้มแล้วก็มีน้ำตาลบางทีก็
เหลืองผู้หญิงชื่ออะไรคะ through  a
อัญมณีอันนี้เม็ดลิงค์อันนี้แหละชื่อ
อำพันอำพัน
อันนั้นจะราคาเป๊าะบุษราคัมอันนี้ปิดปิด
แล้วจะเปิดได้ไหม
อันนี้เพื่อนบอกว่าครูเองกูเองเพิ่งเปิด
ได้
อำพันผู้หญิงแอบมองเห็นอะไรไหมอ่ะผู้หญิง
เหมือนมีอะไรกับเอกทั้งคุยไม่เห็นเลยค่ะ
กูเองไม่คุยอีกอย่างมันจะดูข้างในเหมือน
มันมีมันเปลี่ยนได้สีดำเวลาคู๋หมุนมันก็
เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนที่
ใช่มีอยู่
ถ้าน่ากลัวนะทำไมมีสีดำๆอยู่ข้างใน
เอออะไรได้แล้วโอ๊ะคู่หญิงอันนี้ต้อง 2
ไฟ
แล้วถึงแล้วจะมองเห็นข้างในเหรอใช่อ้า
บุษราคัมอำพันอำพันเนี่ย
อำพันจากจะเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะผู้หญิงมาจากต้น
ไม้
ต้นไม้
เราก็มี
มีทางออกมา
หิวยางต้นไม้แล้วก็เป็นอำพันเหรอหน้า
อย่างต้นไม้แล้วมันทีมีมาแรง
แล้วก็เข้าไปแล้วอำพันขอเอาไว้
แล้วก็คิดนาน
ๆอาจจะ 1,000 ปีด้วยโอโห้
อ๋อ
การในเป็น
อำพันอุ้ยงั้นอำพันก็แพงสิคะ
อันนี้ 500 บาท
ก็ไม่แพงอ๊อดของกูเองไม่มีอะไรข้างในนี้
เล็กๆแต่มีแมลงข้างในอ่ะแพงอะนิดนึงอัน
นี้แบบสวยนิดหน่อยแต่ก็สวยนะกูเอ๋มันดอก
สีส้มสีแดงสีน้ำตาลสีเหลืองสีอะไรไม่อ่า
ซ้ายบางครั้งก็แดงอย่างกันพูดเขาเรียกว่า
สีอำพันคือไม่เชื่อสีแดงไม่ใช่สีส้มไม่
ใช่สีเหลืองผู้ที่บอกทำใครผู้หญิงที่ว่า
สีเหมือนอะไรสีอำพัน
เลือดเหรอคะไม่ใช่
เหมือนอะไรครูเอ๋คิดว่าผู้หญิงไม่รู้
เพื่อนไม่รู้พิมพ์ได้รู้เจียงพูดไม่ได้
เครื่องดื่มอ๋อโอเค
เราเรียกว่าสีอำพันนะคะค่ะอ๋อใช่ค่ะคนไทย
มีแสดงอยู่
สีอำพัน
โอเคเดือนต่อไปเดือนอะไรคะเดือนที่ 12
quay รูปนี้น่ากลัวจะดี 12 เปรียวหาลูก
แต่มันสวยนะ
4 เดือนที่ 12 ค่ะครูเอ๋
เดือนเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคม
เดือน
ตัว S พูดผู้หญิงยังไม่ได้ฝึกกล้วยคะคน
ที่เกิดเดือนธันวาคม
ใส่อัญมณีอะไรคะที่อยู่ในรูปนี้เนี่ยแล้ว
ดีเธอคอยลงเธอคอยนี่สีอะไรคะไม่รู้สิ
อร่อยสีเทอร์คอยส์ไงคู๋สีเธอคอยคือคือสี
ฟ้า
สีฟ้าเขียวเขียวๆเนาะเป็นผู้หญิงอ่ะจะดู
สีฟ้าครูเอ๋ดูสีเขียวรู้เขามีสีเขียว
เขียวๆแล้วก็มีสีฟ้าฟ้าฟ้าฟ้า
มันก็ดีเขียวได้นะกูเอ๋
ก็เป็นเขียวกับฟ้ารวมกันน่ะง่ายเขามีคะมี
สีฟ้าเลยผู้หญิงมีสีม่วงสีฟ้าแบบเนี้ยมี
นะคะแล้วก็สีฟ้าเขียวๆกูเอาไปไหนล่ะ
อันนี้ค่ะเดี๋ยวเอาบอกสีฟ้าเขียวเขียวๆ
เนี่ยก็มีมี 2 สีหูแล้วแล้วก็มีเองให้มี
ล่ะทรายนี่ไงแนวมีป่ะเนี่ยเหมือนตาเลยอ่ะ
อันนี้คนเขามาทำเป็นลูกๆแล้วค่ะอ๋อแต่ลาย
สีดำอันนี้คือเป็นแบบนี้อยู่แล้วใช่ไหมคะ
เป็นลายของเธอคอยอันนี้กูอีกยังไม่รู้ว่า
เธอคอยจริงหรือเธอคอยไม่จริงแต่อันเนี้ย
ของจริงอ่ะ
แล้วปลาก็ใส่เธอคอยสีเธอคอยท์ตัวเอกก็ชอบ
เพลงมีงูถ้า
ไม่มีก็ไม่คุย
เอ็มซีนี่ไม่ใช่เหรอคะไอ้เขียวแบบเนี้ยไป
ไหนแล้วอะช่วยไหมเมื่อก่อนครูเอ๋มีสร้อย
คอไม่ใช่หรอพี่มีคนให้เธอเป็นเขียวๆแบบ
เนี้ยแบบรูปที่เป็นก้อนๆเนี่ยค่ะสีฟ้ามี
หนาให้ออกไปไม่รู้หายหาพระเอกเปลี่ยนไง
ตอนที่ยายบ้านใช่ไหมเว็บเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยน
บ้านก็ของกูเอโอปอล์หายไปเธอเคาะยยหายไป
หมื่นทำไม่มีเงินซื้อนี้ไม่ได้หาย
ไม่มีเงินซื้อต้องบอกไม่ต้องบอก
ไม่ใช่ไม่ถ้าเธอไม่มีเราไม่มีเงินซื้อไม่
ต้องกดอย่าอันนี้กูที่หายไปธนาคาร
เนื้อ
หาๆอ้าวนานเท่าไหร่คะครูเอ๋บุษราคัมเล็กๆ
ก็เป็นหมื่นแล้วผู้หญิงหรอหนู
เห้ย
ค่ะดีแล้วอ่ะผู้หญิงไม่เกิดเดือน
พฤศจิกายนนะ
เอ้า Copy ก็ไม่แพงแล้วนักเรียนรู้หรือ
ยังคะครูเอ๋เกิดเดือนอะไร
โอเคนักเรียนคิดว่าครู x เกิดเดือนอะไร
ๆนักเรียนก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้ถ้านักเรียน
ตอบทุกครูหญิง
ตบมือให้
ไปเรียนกับผู้หญิงฟรี 1 ชั่วโมง
เรียนกับครูเอ๋ฟรี 1 ชั่วโมงค่ะใต้ราคา
เท่านั้นเเหละไรนะคะธ
มีอะไรต้องใส่อะไรแล้วโชคดีทรายน้องนัก
เรียนก็คอมเม้นต์ได้มาขาแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้
หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะครูเอ๋งั้นเราก็ต้องไป
แล้วนะคะนักข่าเล่นอย่าลืมบอกครูว่านัก
เรียนมีอัญมณี
ประจำเดือนเกิดตัวเองไหมนะๆครับผู้หญิง
นี่กูไอ้ให้
เป็นไรเธอหญิง
ตื่นอันนี้นะคะเย้
สวยมากผู้หญิงสวยมากมีไฟก็สวยมากถึงต้อง
ใส่แล้วถ้ากูเองไม่ชอบผู้หญิงตัวเองไม่
ให้นะเนี่ยอะไรเราก็คุยเป็นคนดีนะฮะ
โอเคค่ะทำได้อย่างเงี้ยใช่ก็มาลีให้ผู้
หญิงชอบสีฟ้ายังไงแล้วก็แบบเป็นเดือนเกิด
ของเราแล้วก็แพงแล้วก็ฟรีให้
นักเรียนบอกไม่ชอบครูหญิง
โอเคค่ะผู้หญิงชอบอะไรตรงนี้อีกไหมคะ
ทับทิมทับทิมไม่ชอบอะไรตรงนั้นชอบเขียว
สองอันโอเคให้ค่ะเขียว 2 ให้ได้
แล้วโอเคค่ะเดี๋ยววันนี้เราก็ไปก่อนนอน
แล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่คลิปหน้านะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]